the rest of the day
we have four talks lined up for this
afternoon and then we'll conclude the
day with a panel discussion
and then dinner over at uh free house
which is a five minute walk
from the simons institute so i'm
delighted to introduce our first speaker
of the afternoon davide riso
he is an associate professor of
statistical sciences at the university
of padua
and he will talk to us about the work
that his group has been doing on gene
association networks based on single
cell rna6 thanks very much to everyday
thank you some dream for the invitation
and the kind introduction um so
if it's fine for everybody i'll keep my
mask off so it's easier um to to follow
my uh talk so um
i just uh um thought that uh i'll spend
a couple of slides introducing a single
seller in asic just because
you know
everybody was sort of like diving into
the topic with no
introduction i'm sure
many of you know already but like just
uh so that we're on on the same page the
idea is that if we have a complex organ
like the brain in hugging case um uh we
could until
you know maybe 10 years ago or so we
could only do like bulk rna-seq right we
could just take the
piece of organ just chop it up and just
measure the gene expression
averaging expression across all the
different cell types um nowadays we have
these single cell or nac protocols where
basically we can
uh characterize the rna profiles of each
individual cell and then we can do
something like bioinformatically like
clustering this different cell types and
then measuring sort of cell type
specific expression um of genes or
isoforms uh in these cases and as you
can imagine this opens up a lot of
different questions so what are uh cell
type specific markers or um sort of like
is there disease-associated cell types
or cell states and uh whether we can do
like some sort of like
comparison between different tissues but
uh at a cell type a specific way
so um the
uh
i guess the first part of my
introduction is about count models for
rna-seq data because this data in the
case of rna sequencing is essentially um
uh counts in the sense that we map reads
to to genes and then we can essentially
count how many reads we have and that's
our estimate of gene expression and you
can sort of imagine this in a very
simplistic way as a simple random
sampling of the reads across the genome
in this case across you know the
expressed accents and if we do that
essentially what we can
the way we can model these data is as a
binomial process which we have some
total number of uh reads for our sample
and then basically the probability of
observing a read from our gene is
essentially the true expression of the
gene and
proportional to the length of that gene
and
since we have many many weeds and many
many genes so this individual pj is
quite small we can actually
approximate that very well with the
poisson process right and that's you
know the most simplistic way you can
think about these data
except that when you look at real data
sets and you do something like this
where every point is a gene you have the
mean expression level and and the
variance for each gene uh you see that
by a poisson model you would expect uh
sort of this equivalence
situation and you have uh sort of like
this over dispersion that you observed
in the data so this is mainly due to
biological viability across your samples
uh but it means that the poisson is
probably not um a good model for many of
these genes and so people have
introduced this negative binomial
distribution as a as a way as a very
simple way of of dealing with this over
dispersion
this is the formula of the negative
binomial that's not very important what
is important is that um it basically
characterizes the variance of your
counts as a quadratic function of the
mean and this is you know what the
classic sort of differential expression
um uh papers um uh do they assume this
distribution and it's also uh sort of
like a special case of this distribution
is the poisson when the dispersion
parameter um tends to zero
the uh good thing about this model is
that it's it's kind of simple
computationally and it's also very good
in terms of interpretation in the sense
that you can in sort of imagine that the
variance is split in two components one
that can kind of represents the
technical component so if you increase
your your mean you increase the number
of reads that sort of tends to go to
zero but then you have sort of like a
fixed uh parameter that is sort of like
biological uh variability it's not
really dependent on on the
on the sequencing technology
and um this is all fine for bulk rna-seq
where you have sort of uh if you have
two technical replicates of a typical
bulk rna-seq sample you see that most
genes sort of like line up across the
diagonal meaning that all of these sort
of technical variability can be uh
represented by the poisson and then on
top of that you have the biological
variability that is well captured by the
negative binomial when you look at
single cell level even with technical
replicates you see that you have much
more variability and also a lot more
zeros um in the data right so these are
for example all genes that are zero in
replicate two but are kind of like
expressed at a high number of reads in
uh replicate one and the same here for
replicate two
so um
what people us and other people have
sort of tried to do in this with this
state i think about
how to kind of model this extra zero
that we see in the data and uh one way
to do that is to use this you inflate a
negative binomial like uh jessie was
showing uh earlier that essentially puts
an extra probability of observing the
zero
in addition to the typical uh
distribution of a negative binomial uh
proportion of zeros and uh essentially
you can you can uh interpret this
parameter pi as the sort of prior
probability that the zero is observed
instead of your sort of count uh read
count uh typical of a negative binomial
distribution
so this is um we're gonna get back to
this in a few slides to see what is the
actual uh sort of uh
reasonable model to to model single
seller and seek data but this is quite a
general model in the sense that for pi
equal to
zero it essentially boils down to the
negative binomial distribution and again
when in this case i'm sorry i'm using a
slightly different notation but with
this theta parameter um a special case
of the sort of limiting case of this
would be the poisson so you can kind of
recover all of the different uh
distribution poisson negative binomials
zero inflated poisson and zero inflate
the negative binomial with this sort of
general model
so the problem is
that in a lot of these differential
expression papers uh what they do they
they model each gene independently right
then they use some kind of like maybe
empirical based approach to kind of uh
be more robust to this sort of
assumption but like essentially all that
uh it relates to the dependency
structure of the data is sort of thrown
away um and you know a good exception is
you know jessica's model that actually
tries to model that with a copper right
but like i would say that ninety percent
of at least the volcanic sick papers
they sort of like make this uh gene
independence assumption and and that's
what we want to kind of like uh uh
sort of uh overcome right and there are
obviously many many different ways in
which you can account for these sort of
uh dependencies across genes and one of
them is this sort of graphical models
approach so i guess my second
introduction is a little bit of an
introduction in this general class of
models which are called graphical models
so the idea of graphical models really
sort of like boils down to the idea of
conditional independence um in the sense
that if you imagine to have three random
variables x1 x2 and x3 you can sort of
define
this idea of conditional independence
and this sort of equation uh is right in
in this way x1 is conditionally
independent of x3 uh given x2 and this
essentially means that if we have some
sort of
you know law distribution
likelihood whatever you want to call it
of x1 given x2 and x3 this is exactly
equal to the distribution of x1 given x2
and in you know other words essentially
knowing x2 renders x3 completely
relevant in trying to explain or predict
x1 right so this um
is nice in my opinion for a few
different ways and first of all it's
kind of intuitive to think about gene
independences in this kind of way so
maybe there's a um
there's there's a nice uh sort of
interpretation of this in the context of
gene expression but it's also a very
nice computational tool in the sense
that you know if we want to characterize
the joint distribution of you know three
random variables x1 x2 x3
because of this assumption now we can
essentially uh sort of factorize the
distribution in two components right for
example uh in in various ways for
example um looking at a bivariate
distribution of x1 x2 and then um the
distribution of x3 given x2 right so so
essentially we're taking a a three
dimensional sort of problem and we're uh
reducing it to a two dimensional problem
which is nice from a computational point
of view too
so um the
nice thing is about graphical models is
that these conditional independencies
can be sort of represented with graphs
and and this i think it's a very good
feature because you know
in some sense networks and graphs are a
sort of common language between
statisticians and biologists right
biologists are very used to graphs and
and sort of like networks and they have
an intuitive understanding of those as
well even
without thinking about conditional
independences in this case so this
relation that i was looking at before x1
is in conditional independent on x3
given x2 can be represented with this
very simple graph and in this sense uh
you know you have an edge between the
nodes if there isn't a conditional
independence so because x1 and x2 are
not conditionally independent then you
have an edge
in this case the only missing edge is
one and three because we have this
conditional independence
statement okay and so this um going back
to the to the uh
sort of uh factorization of the
likelihood um can be seen in terms of
clicks in the graph which is also a nice
uh sort of feature so for example you
can take um you know this uh
um
one two which would be a click in our in
our graph and and sort of like take the
joint distribution of these two
variables and then take this uh
condition on the on the on the only one
that is connected to three in this case
which is two or you could do the other
way around with this uh certain
factorization
so um
the the what what i'm essentially
explained is what people in statistics
call probabilistic graphical model and
just to be a little more formal in the
definition a probabilistic graphical
model is essentially defined as a pair
the pair is like the two components of
the pair are the graph g which is the
usual sort of definition of a graph a
set of vertices b and a set of edges e
and then you have on top of that a
certain family of distribution f which
represents essentially the probability
distributions of the nodes on the on the
graph and as i said essentially uh if
you have like an edge s between the
nodes s and t in your set of edges e uh
that um
essentially implies the conditional
independence between circle sorry the
absence of the edge
implies the conditional independence
between the two nodes s and t given uh
everything else uh all the other nodes
so um this is sort of like actually an
assumption that we need to make in the
in the graph which is uh
sometimes called the fatefulness
assumption meaning that we can read off
all of these conditional distributions
from the graph only and uh you know
these are sort of like
a very simple example of a graph just to
give you an idea of what these
properties of the graph are which are
called the markov properties
so we have sort of the
global markov property which is this one
which essentially says that you know two
sets of nodes are conditionally
independent of each other given sort of
a separator of the graph so if you kind
of separate these two sets of nodes in
this case one uh against three and four
uh the separator is essentially just the
set of nodes that interrupts the path
between the two sets right and so in
this case you have that one is
conditionally independent of three and
four given two and five this is sort of
like the global markov property and then
we have also the local markov property
so for example um
the global markup property says that you
know if you focus for example on gene
five or you know node five and node
three these two are independent given
all of its neighbors right so basically
five is conditional independent of three
um conditioned on two and four because
essentially every path that goes from
five to three has to go through either
four or two
okay and then we have the pairwise
markov property which essentially says
that for any kind of uh
set of nodes like pair of nodes like in
this case one and five they are
conditional and dependent on the rest of
the graph um so if you if one and five
are conditionally independent
conditioned on the right or rest of the
a very good thing about these sort of
markov properties is that if you have a
certain set of conditions which is
essentially true for all uh you know
reasonable uh probability distributions
these three are equivalent okay so um
you can sort of like look at the graph
and infer all of these properties
of conditional independence is just
looking at the graph
so
you know we're not the first ones to
think about applying this sort of
graphical models framework to gene
expression this was done by
a lot of people actually i'm citing just
a couple but just to say that there are
essentially two possible ways that you
can think about applying these graphical
models to gene expression data one is
just to inform better inform your
differential expression model okay so
you're saying like i want to compare for
example condition a versus composition b
uh instead of doing it like
independently gene by gene i can take
for example a
pathway transform that into a graph um
and then basically saying okay i'm i'm
instead of testing one gene at a time
i'm now just testing one pathway at a
time using the multivariate distribution
of the genes in the pathway and this was
done uh in a couple of papers one by
sandrine
actually a few years ago
and
the other thing which is the focus on
this talk is actually structural
learning
try to
learn the structure of the graph so this
kind of a set of conditional
independences starting from the data and
the idea here is that you have your
matrix of gene expression and you want
to try sort of to
estimate some kind of graph that
represents sort of the the structure and
the association between these genes
so uh just to get to the
core of the uh talk um what we do is
that uh we take a sort of note
conditional approach so we specified the
distribution of the node condition on
all the other nodes and this is uh we
assume that this is a zero-inflated
negative binomial distribution and as i
said before this is not really a
statement on whether we think that the
data are zero inflated or not it's just
that it's the most general model and by
using this we can just kind of like
recover all the other cases uh as a
as a either special cases or limiting
cases and then what we do essentially we
take a local approach in which
essentially we assume that the
distribution of our gene i uh sorry our
um
uh
our uh gene s
is sort of uh uh can be written as a as
a regression on all the other genes um
of the net of sort of the network that
we are estimating okay so essentially
this is a a a regression model that in
principle uh explains the expression of
our gene s given all of the other genes
in the network and then we will estimate
this beta to be zero for some genes and
that would mean that we have an absence
of an edge in that particular
gene pair
so
this type of approach to structural
learning is not something we invented
it's a kind of a general class of
structure learning algorithm which is
called the pc algorithm and essentially
what it does is starts from the complete
graph so assuming that you know all the
genes are connected to all the other
genes and then essentially it tests
these null hypotheses that in this case
we actually have
two um sort of regressions in the most
general case because we have both the
regression and mu which is kind of a
long linear model and a regression on pi
which is kind of a logistic model um so
we assume our null hypothesis is that
all of these sort of betas all these
coefficients of the two regressions for
a particular pair of genes s and t are
equal to zero and we test that for
essentially each gene pair and and we
use simply like a deviant's test
statistic to them so if the null
hypothesis is rejected then it means
there exists an edge between s and t if
the null hypothesis is not rejected that
means that we can sort of remove the
edge from the graph
so of course doing that for every
possible pair of genes um would be kind
of too much computationally and that's
kind of like the core of the pc
algorithm which you know i took this
slide from uh from this paper here in
which they they sort of present it in
general
the idea is again with this very simple
graph with just four nodes uh you start
with the simple with the with the actual
most complex graph so all the edges uh
are present and essentially you start
with the um level one or a degree one so
you essentially do for example for your
uh node a you look at the univariate
regression
of a on b and then on c and then on d
okay and then you basically will have
only one beta to estimate the one beta
to test for each of these and if you um
sort of reject it then um you remove the
you keep the edge if you don't reject it
you remove the edge in this case for
example we can remove uh for example b
and c and c and d then we move to the
degree two in which we basically regress
every node on two
neighbors
in this case for example a against b and
d and if we see that one beta is uh
different from zero then we uh sort of
like uh we remove one edge and we go on
until either we reach a maximum degree
that we specify or we reach like a
situation in which we don't
remove any more edges
so just to give you some technical
remarks that i don't have time to go
into this
in this talk so we
control these neighborhood sites with
this parameter m which is essentially
this degree that i just uh talked about
um we proved the consistency of this
algorithm
assuming the fatefulness of the node
conditional distribution and we can
prove that that exists in the case of
competitive relationship between genes
and uh we have a sort of a procedure to
estimate the type uh
to control the type one error in the
sense of the family was error rate and
um
one sort of assumption that we make is
that there are no related confounders so
uh essentially that you know all of the
relationship that we see among genes
there are no like hidden variables that
we then didn't take into account
and of course you can in this framework
allowed for observed covariates or
observed sort of uh confounders for
example batch effects but we don't have
a way to kind of deal with hidden vector
files
so just to show you uh
quickly uh some
[Music]
some do we have ten minutes okay so i'll
show you quickly some simulation results
so in this case um we simulate with sort
of a large mean meaning that the genes
are quite largely uh highly expressed um
in terms of number of reads and in this
case everything is as you would imagine
like if we uh simulate uh data from a
poisson then essentially all the models
work well um you know maybe the zoom b
works a little
worse if we assume uh we simulate data
with the negative binomial then the
negative binomial also works well but
the poisson starts failing and if you
assume uh we simulate from zero inflated
negative binomial we need the zero
inflated negative so this is kind of
like a boring simulation result what is
more interesting is that if you now
simulate the data with a smaller mean
which is typical of what we observe in
for example umi based single cell data
then
something a little more surprising
happens which is that even when we
simulate from a zero-inflated negative
binomial even a simple poisson model
works well
um and uh so this sort of like
corroborates i guess the the idea that
we don't need this sort of like
complicated zero-inflated models for umi
data but maybe in a in a slightly
different way that people usually think
about that
so just to give you a little more
details on that
here we're simply
sort of measuring the hullinger distance
between the two distributions the
negative binomial and the zero-inflated
negative binomial um at uh as a function
of pi
um and as a function of the dispersion
parameter uh so use and and as a mean
so you see that when you have a small
mean
and uh especially when we have a large
uh variance uh we see that even for
ninety percent of zero inflation so data
simulated with pi equal 0.9 in the zero
inflator negative model um the um
[Music]
the
difference between the distance between
the two distribution is quite small so
to me what this means is that when you
have small counts it doesn't really
matter what the data generating
distribution is a simple model would
just work as fine just because in terms
of uh
inferential sense in the distance space
they're very similar
so just in the last five minutes or so
i'll i'll just uh give you an idea of
how to apply this to uh real data so uh
the the case study that that i have here
is by john nylab who um you know many of
you know um it's um it's about the mouse
of factory epithelium which is sort of a
system that we studied to kind of that
we used to study sort of uh uh you know
how stem cells mature into neurons and
other uh mature cell types and so this
is sort of like a a simple system that
has only a handful of mature cell types
so it's kind of nice to in that sense
and it has a stem cell niche so
essentially what we can observe with
single cell data is sort of like all of
these sort of different stages of uh
development of these olfactory stem
cells they're also called the horizontal
basal cells up all the way to neurons
and we have um sort of like a
a few data sets on that we have
uh the the latest data that uh the nylab
collected is is a set of 20 000 plus uh
single cells doing done with the single
uh with its next genomics technology
here is a sort of like a heat map of
some interesting genes ordered by sort
of the pseudotime
developmental order from stem cells to
neuron and you can see that there's a
lot of coordination among genes like
some genes that are
high in expression early on some genes
that are high later on and some kind of
in the middle and these um you know can
sort of like be represented quite well
with uh with sort of uh graphs and in
particular here we're focusing on
transcription factor genes
and so this is sort of uh the kind of
transcription factor dynamics across
development what we do we sort of take
this uh uh stage of uh olfactory um uh
stem cells and see like this is just a
way uh which is called hive plots to
represent a graph with a lot of
connection otherwise it looks a lot like
a four ball um but essentially what we
do then we cluster the nodes using some
kind of community detection algorithm
and run some genset enrichment analysis
on that and you can see that you know
all of these kind of make a lot of sense
so we see a lot of cell cycle and cell
differentiation early on in the
trajectory uh then we have some uh
signaling and cell proliferation and all
the way up to material where we have
chromatin organization and and sort of
signaling uh pathways starting to pop up
and then we sort of like focus on this i
guess crucial stage which is the
activated hbcs which are the stem cells
that have been activated and sort of uh
the fate is decided that they're gonna
differentiate and um and if we look more
closely to uh the sets of uh
genes that are sort of connected to this
transcription factor t53 we see a lot of
uh sort of genes that we would expect
like socks 11 and
cdh2 etc and uh in particular if we
focus on the direct neighbors of p63 we
see many of the confirmed targets by
gypsy so we think that our
approach is kind of working uh well in
this case
so just to give you a little bit of uh
conclusions and a
sense of what this is going in terms of
development
the um
we kind of think that we're on the right
track because we're able to kind of give
biological insects in this particular
data set we have actually a different uh
data set as well that i didn't have time
to present uh but the idea is that now
we want to kind of like extend it to
include this kind of like pseudotime or
space uh element into it so kind of like
thinking about dynamic networks that you
know networks that change in either in
sudo time or in space for spatial
transcriptomics and we can uh rely on on
there's a lot of uh results in the
statistical literature for some time
like multivariate time series that we
can we can sort of leverage and um and
then of course the other
interesting
direction is to look at multi-ohmic data
and see if we can sort of like use this
sort of market graph or chain graphs to
kind of like allow for connections
between for example chromatin at
an answer or promoters to inform gene
expression
and um i just want to thank my research
group in particular this work was done
for the most part by kim who is a
postdoc in my lab and
and
and by these two collaborators kuhn that
uh used to be a postdoc here at berkeley
and uh monica who is uh in bologna and
of course uh the nylab for the data and
for the um
good uh sort of uh back and forth that
we had on the on the biological
significance of these uh analysis so
thank you for the attention and
everything that i sort of uh mentioned
is in this preprint and then you can
also kind of like try to
uh apply this yourself with this our
package that we have on github
thank you very much davide so are there
any questions
that was really nice one question that
comes to mind when think about
conditional dependencies it is
implicitly probing with the pc algorithm
right is that you're
having
sparse measurements uh
you know of the latent quantities
actually induce the conditional
dependence you know often the variables
that actually create independencies
might be
those you measure the least well like
transcription factors and other elements
so so how do you see that in terms of
limitations and how to adapt the pc
algorithms is that already catered for
or is there more work needed yeah no i
mean i guess there is one key assumption
right that is that the graph is parse
right if the graph is not sparse then
like the pc algorithm is not working
well um which is one thing like sparse
in terms of number of edges compared to
the full graph right um
but yeah in the case of like uh the the
main problem is i don't i don't think
it's so much with the um
i mean the main problem with the
sparsity of the data in terms of
expression of genes is that you have to
kind of do some kind of filtering based
on gene expression right if a gene has
only like one read in one cell you're
not going to be able to get much
information about that and unfortunately
that is true that transcription factors
are often uh lowly expressed um what
happens in that case is that you get
these sort of spurious um
conditional independences right that
instead of
that you know because that node is
missing you have sort of like uh the the
closest measured node that that sort of
acts as the at the hub node instead of
that so we don't really have a good um
a good solution to that but that's what
i hope this multiomic data will be able
to kind of like provide us with because
if we can now use uh epigenomics data as
a kind of like in between layer maybe we
have transcription factor has a low
expression but then if we see like a
good an answer signal at
the gene at the target gene maybe we can
sort of like
the hub node well the the connection
will become the an answer
versus or the promoter to the gene
expression and then we can sort of like
infer which is the transcription factor
that binds there
yeah thank you very nice talk i just
have two questions the first one is that
did you compare your approach right you
did this direct count modeling approach
to this log transform data and then you
can use the gaussian graphic yeah yeah
yeah
that word easier i guess
i skipped that slide yeah but i have it
somewhere here
um
yeah so
yeah um we did a little bit of that um
let's see if we can make this bigger um
so yeah so the log transformation is
really bad idea um in the sense that it
works well when you have a very high
expression um but it's obviously like
not really helpful for um data when you
have very low counts right um other
approaches like the copyload or these
randomized quantile receivables which is
very similar i guess to to the coupler
in terms of um
well i guess it's a different mechanism
to get to what you were doing in terms
of like uh getting the copula right for
non-continuous data so these work well
at the uh sort of like uni univariate
level when you actually look at
uh
you know this is simulated data so you
know um
but in the case of simulated data what
we see
is that um when you especially when you
have low counts so here we're simulating
with the poisson so the kind of like the
purple line which is the poisson is sort
of the ground truth uh when you have low
counts especially but it seems that if
if you have a very large n then the the
sort of uh this is a f1 score of the of
the different models start to kind of
degrade and i think the reason for that
is that gaussian graphical models assume
gaussianity and so when you have very
very large sample size
even a tiny difference from the null
hypothesis will make it uh
and so what happens here is that
basically we uh reject all the null
hypothesis uh when you have an big
enough and these are not like you know
unusual numbers for single cell data so
that's why we didn't
take that approach for now but yeah this
is sort of also ongoing so yeah thank
you and my second question is regarding
this conditional independence versus
like pairwise dependence comparison so
because i think your model can also be
used to do just the pairwise
relationship between two genes right
it's a different perspective like i feel
like probably for biologists they want
to see
how different the results will be and
what are the biological implications the
two different graphs
right so you're meaning instead of
conditional independence like kind of
straight straight independence yeah yeah
yeah um yeah i mean there is there is a
literature on like those graphical
models for like uh
direct dependencies yeah which we could
uh definitely look into
so uh can i have a question uh when you
are talking about the structure learning
you said uh you have a complete graph i
assuming uh
a data graph is homogeneous about
the each node the node in that graph is
all about the genes
so
uh how do we capture
all the sales so all the so in that
complete graph uh we'll capture all the
sales or just about one
sale yeah um
yeah i if i understand correctly the
question i think uh you have a good
point in the sense that if you have like
a heterogeneous set of cells then um
essentially our approach assumes that
it's a homogeneous population of cells
right that's uh another way of saying
like there's no latent confounder right
that there's uh so in this case what we
did it's a very simplistic approach
which probably is also double dipping so
uh that could be an issue as well but uh
that we took this sort of clustering of
data and it's different cell types and
then we uh estimate the structure of the
graph independently for each uh
cluster of cells um that's what i mean
here when i say that we want to have
this dynamic network sort of try to add
that component into the
algorithm that's still not the case in
this case so yeah
all right thanks for all the questions
and thanks davide thank you